well since the beginning of the pandemic
several african countries have been
calling for a patent waiver on covet 19
vaccines so far without a result but now
an mrna hub for africa the first of its
kind is being set up in cape town it
aims to copy the moderna vaccine and our
correspondent adrian krisch has this
report
it's a first for the continent this
inconspicuous building in an industrial
area of cape town is the base for
africa's mrna vaccine technology hub
with vaccines in short supply in africa
the who and kovacs initiative led the
drive to set up a local technology
sharing platform that's one of the
positive legacies of covet we now in the
last eight months have seen this this
this massive funding available now for
biotechnology in south africa in cape
town and also in africa afrigen is the
company tasked with developing and
producing mrna vaccines these are
relatively new but highly effective
vaccines that so far only two major
companies have commercialized biontec
and moderna efrigen was counting on a
cooperation with modern the model was
that we will receive a technology
transfer turnkey technology transfer but
that didn't happen so the team now has
jumped in with our university partners
and the knowledge base in south africa
to develop our own backseat
one of the key partners is in
johannesburg the anti-viral gene therapy
research unit at whitwater's rand
university
they've been working on mrna technology
since 2015
as one of the only research units on the
continent they are now sharing their
skills and knowledge with african
we have been able to take information
which is available in the public domain
to work out how the moderna mrna is
produced so we have the sequence and we
have the context of that sequence
which we've been able to reproduce but
of course the purpose of that really is
to use as a reference
rather than as something which we want
to try and
use as a as a product
so we would like to develop our own
ideas and we are in fact doing that
already
and compare that to the moderna
vaccine
back in cape town pietro tablanche is
still hoping moderna comes on board as
this would speed up the process modena
has announced a patent waiver while the
pandemic is still ongoing but afterwards
no commercialization will be possible
without its approval
we would like to have a voluntary
license to be able to transfer this
technology to other low and middle
income countries to use the platform for
other vaccines hiv tb ebola flu this hub
and the capacity capability we're
building here
is is beyond covert so this this in fact
is part of a strategy from from africa
to produce 60 of our vaccines by 2040.
so this is part of building an industry
today most vaccines used on the
continent are imported afrijin and its
partners aim to bring the first
homegrown products to market within
three
years and now i'd like to bring in
candace sahoma she is an access campaign
officer for doctors without borders and
she joins us now from johannesburg a
very warm welcome to the show candace
how optimistic are you that an african
developed mrna vaccine would make covert
19 shots more available across the
continent
yeah thank you so much for having me i
think i am very optimistic and you know
it's something that we have been calling
for as a civil society um looking at the
current um disparities when it comes to
vaccine access in particular in africa
we have seven percent of our population
only vaccinated um having a broader
manufacturing of these
vaccines would enable access it would
you know enable um as as you might know
that you know an issue that we encounter
in in africa in particular is an issue
around supply and broadening
manufacturing would enable um africa to
be able to be more independent and
supply um it's it's it's it's countries
or its people um to get vaccinated now
they're still working on this project
but time is of the essence in this
pandemic would it not make more sense to
change patent laws forcing big
pharmaceutical firms to actually allow
african companies to produce more of
their vaccines
yeah and i think it's as you mentioned
like time is of the essence and you know
it would make so much of a difference if
we
had this trip's waiver as you know that
south africa and india have actually
proposed a waiver on patents um on all
covered 19 medical tools um it would
actually save us more time as it will
expedite the process of sharing this
technology with all the respective um
capable manufacturers and also knowing
that we do have capable manufacturers in
the continent um you know msf has done
analysis um looking at you know um
capability in africa of of companies
that can
manufacture mrna and vaccine technology
you know so we do have the the capacity
what is needed now is that sharing of
technology and there's already
initiatives like the mrna have that has
been established to be able to transfer
this technology so if we were to have
you know companies originator companies
sharing this technology with um the mrna
hub that would expedite the process of
us getting um
uh manufacturing these vaccines it would
shorten you know the length of it as as
you know that with the mrna hub they
need like a timeline of about three
years if we would have you know in an
existing um technology like faizad
modena sharing their technology with the
hap that would shorten the time to about
a year where we can able to to
manufacture this vaccine so i think that
process that sharing of technology is a
very key um element and also kind of
waving um patents is a very
critical um
solution that is needed to expedite the
process of upscaling manufacturing i
also want to ask you about a couple
other tools in the fight against covet
19 namely things like tests things like
medical equipment from your daily
experience working with doctors without
borders in south africa what are the
biggest barriers to making sure people
do have access to those tools
yeah and i think it's similarly i mean
even earlier in the pandemic we
experience a lot of you know shortages
when it comes to um accessing these
medical
tools like testing testing tools so and
as you know that we also
recently
encountered expert burns bans or other
travel bans which has unfortunately is
also kind of affecting even operations
we we are anticipating to get you know
testing um tools from other um parts of
the world however due to the current um
bans on you know south africa that in
itself affects our ability to actually
receive those those those testing uh
material to be able to um test um
patients in our in our operations so
unfortunately you know those are the
kind of um uh uh
sort of challenges that we that were
encountered much more broadly that um
countries have also imposed um export
bans and that's why um we are calling
for um you know sharing and
collaboration to enable um countries
like south africa with you know and that
they don't need to actually rely on
other countries um to be able to have
these testing we do have the
manufacturing capacity what is needed is
for for the technology to be shared so
that we can manufacture and be able to
better respond um to the demand in our
own countries without having to rely to
other um countries who have um
unfortunately imposed these um
restrictions okay so a call for more
sharing and what is ultimately a global
struggle a candidacy homo we're going to
leave it there thank you so much for
joining us on the show
thank you thank you so much for having
me